تعود جذور نظام هيئه المحلفين الى الاباء
المؤسسين لدستور الولايات المتحده عام
1765 حيث استدعى في كل عام الاف من
المواطنين الامريكيين للانضمام لهيئات
المحلفين يتخذ قرار الحكم بناء على الادله
والحقائق التي يطلع عليها اعضاء هيئه
المحلفين اذ يصدرون بعد سماع حيثيات
القضيه ومجرياتها قرارا ويقدمونه للقاضي
للبت في القضيه يوجد نوعان من هيئات
المحلفين الهيئه الصغرى والهيئه الكبرى
وللعضويه في هيئه المحلفين شروط عده اهمها
ان يكون شخص مواطنا امريكيا عمره لا يقل
عن 18 عاما وامضى ما لا يقل عن سنه في
الولايات التي يسكنها وان يكون قادرا على
التحدث باللغه الانجليزيه بطلاقه ولا يوجد
لديه اي عائق نفسي او جسدي ولم يسبق ان
حكم عليه في قضيه يستثنى من عضويه هيئات
المحلفين المنتسبون للجيش والشرطه وحكام
المدن والحكام الفيدراليون هيئه المحلفين
الصغرى تضم ما بين سته الى 12 شخصا وتكون
علنيه ولكن مداولاتها خاصه اذ يتمتع
المتهم بحق المثول امامها للشهاده
واستدعاء الشهود وغالبا تختص الهيئه
الصغرى بقضايا مدنيه او جنائيه اما هيئه
المحلفين الكبرى فتكون لقضايا مهمه يرفعها
عاده المدعي العام في الولايه وتتكون من
16 الى 23 شخصا ولا تكون مداولتها مفتوحه
كما لا يحق للمتهمين ومحاميهم المثول امام
هيئه المحلفين الكبرى ويمكن لهيئه
المحلفين الكبرى مثل تلك التي واجهت
الاتهامات ترامب الاستماع الى قضايا
متعدده في الوقت ذاته وقد تكون هناك
انقطاعات في جدول اعمالها تمتد لايام
وتعمل هيئه المحلفين الكبرى كذراء للمحكمه
ولي
وهي لا تحدد ما اذا كان المتهم مجرما او
بريئا لكنها تحدد ما اذا كان يجب توجيه
تهمه رسميه لشخص ما بارتكاب جريمه بعد
الاطلاع على الادله وشهاده المدعين
العامين وتكون صلاحيات هيئه المحلفين
الكبرى ضمن ثلاثه خيارات اولا التصويت على
لائحه الاتهام ثانيا التصويت لرفض الاتهام
ثالثا توجيه المدعين العامين لتقديم لائحه
اتهام اقل خطوره